hello and welcome to the video playing
Moscow clue shin muscles in the mother
yeah we'll see what happens I'm going to
do something different ettore attacker
not nothing that i usually play but why
not it's a very Sun set up and will
actually get some center here not bad
black set up its own and quite modest or
maybe he's he's got some point that I
don't quite get yet some tactical I
don't know no it just looks okay for
white should be six maybe I'd like to
prevent that
yeah it looks very very sound position
question is if I should commit in the
center or not I don't really want you
know some something like a five is
giving away I think quite important
quite important squares okay interesting
so I don't want to trade some taking all
your 7s out of the out of the question
so just retreating
I don't want to trade because I've got
more space so usually trading then
doesn't make much sense he probably
wants to play five so I'm I should be
ready for that if I by gaudi 594 Bishop
takes it takes and night be three wins
the default port I think I can he does
not do that he goes back okay here maybe
Bishop a6 does make some sense
94 is also an interesting move but there
is I don't really have to don't really
have to do anything drastic I just have
a very nice space advantage it doesn't
have any pawn moves down
hmm 94 he has to play almost has to play
d 596 DX e 6 this is not clear right
let's not kid is not clear okay um night
be three looks wrong though the night is
just wrong one d to this is the this is
the sad truth okay let's let's at least
try to make a sophisticated looking move
after I spent spent that that much time
that is to play Bishop to a six and then
potentially 95 play on the light squares
and I can try to double like Roxy 2 and
so on so he's probably shooting for 96
again but I don't think I don't think
this various me
see going for be five maybe nope okay
not sure about be five but I have to do
something now don't want to shuffle
around any longer night a form that
looks strong actually as I guess now he
goes back so I have a good control you
5sd hug he wants to go Knight to d7 yeah
I guess this is probably correct try to
use that momentum maybe you can take and
play night to see 5 this is possible
Knight to e5 okay if three is a passive
move though don't really want to play
that
I wonder if cage for something no way
six is first of all hanging them Queen
f6 though is now came neither three is
still not a thread se6 is under attack
that's a nice position I think main
issue is the time he's sitting on quite
a quite some weaknesses I'm morning so
then I can check on h4 for a repetition
but it was a quick move justice also we
will worth something how to do it this
and Queen d2 yeah Queen g6
h3 is not threatening much I think
20 seconds the usual problem Bishop
before is probably completely incorrect
with take stakes it's not even sure that
this is totally incorrect check no
Castle is spindle the draw here maybe he
will try to win on time yeah I'm just
threaten to take on age 3 so objectively
speaking it cannot play for win
yeah check yeah it was bad I just have
to win the game of course here why this
completely winning but I couldn't find
find a way in that time to to make it
make it easier maybe I just have to play
age three and it weakens the dark
squares but I just have to trade Queens
or prevent any any of this silly counter
place just age three I guess back and it
is on plus for I am just to show what
this is this is a dead piece a
completely dead piece you've been any
any n kemia black spawn structures it's
really really funny ok mean this this is
also winning but it's it's it's not so
easy to do with the time ok here it's
actually easy to do I can check and take
age three and it's plus a million job I
don't know when did I spent I spent lots
of time early in the game and then then
he caught up yeah i think it was it was
a just a better position here out of the
opening white has better center
concentric control and he had no
particularly clear idea what to do and
gradually he got he got outplayed him
have to be five here he has to take this
is clearly better than a five after this
now the position becomes very ugly for
black it's very difficult very difficult
to play he's sitting on those weaknesses
even though this is the this is the
final and problem after this he gets he
gets this lost structure yeah it is just
a completely dead p zombie 7 yeah i
should matter I should manage to win
this who win it on the crocuses enough
to do it but term
not in this game not in this game okay
thanks for watching